you don't meet the person that you want
to marry and then decide you want to get
married you decide you want to get
married and then you meet the person you
want to marry because it's a different
heads space it's the difference between
saying I'm going to toss five bucks at a
penny stock and saying I'm going to
spend $100,000 investing this portfolio
$5 in a penny stock who cares but when
you're investing like a full portfolio
for a 30-year period you better damn
well be thinking about what exactly your
principles are when it comes to a
relationship you have to be thinking
like what is life going to be like 15
years from now so we've married for 15
years now and our life is four children
and those children rely on us to be
solid and to show them what a good
relationship looks like and to be there
for them and even if we're frustrated to
keep that frustration within certain
boundaries so my dad and I quote this
all the time he always says that in
order for people to get married you have
to make the pre-commitment in your mind
that you're ready to get married